they came here to escape the horrors of
war but now the fighting is largely done
their future does not look any less
bleak this one tent is shared by four
families from afghanistan's northern
province of tajar like maryam a widowed
mother of six who says she had to sell
possessions to move here and escape the
conflict
no one helped us when we came here we
sold the tv and a carpet and have been
economizing like eating less but the
money ran out three days ago we're not
in good shape
located on the outskirts of kabul this
open piece of land was overrun with
displaced people as the taliban closed
in on the capital and as the government
attempted to move them to more organized
camps
with the collapse of that government has
come the end of any official help adding
to kabul's growing crisis of people
displaced by war
their journeys began from places where
the conflict has raged around
afghanistan in recent months and the
taliban victory has brought a degree of
stability but for many still no clearer
idea of where to go next
on the other side of this shared tent
khulam hazarat wants to take his family
of nine back to their home
but he doesn't know if the house he is
still paying rent on is even standing
we don't have any money left to go back
and set up again in our old place if the
government can look after us that's
better
right now that government doesn't exist
yet when it does it'll be up to the
taliban to provide support
and tackle the many other crises facing
afghanistan rob mcbride al jazeera kabul